hello then welcome back more now on the
situation in Sudan with tens of
thousands trying to still flee the
country at least 16 000 have crossed the
border into Egypt but there's pressure
on all of the nation's borders
compounding what is already a fought
situation for the East African countries
neighbors Let's uh bring in now Carl
schembry a spokesperson on Sudan for the
Norwegian Refugee councilor Carl good to
have you with us evening and thank you
very much for your time out that much
really busy for your organization just
um talks about the situation
um as you understand it it's some of
those border crossings for people trying
to leave the fighting
foreign
well it's it's a very unclear picture so
far because uh we don't really have
accurate figures of people trying to
cross and the parts of the crossings
that they are using are leading to uh
pretty deprived areas which uh need uh
all the support of the International
Community we've heard people crossing
into Egypt taking days uh queuing at the
border uh the picture is less clear
what's happening in Chad and South Sudan
but these are all countries
that need international support so that
they can keep the borders open it's
really imperative that they keep the
borders open to these hundred percent
genuine refugees fleeing the unthinkable
what's folding in front of us is a
terrifying nightmare when you think that
what is happening inside Sudan is
happening while the world is watching uh
it's just Unthinkable how this might
develop when the world will stop paying
attention yeah and as we're reporting
this evening it's
um
being being announced by the Sudanese
Army that they have extended their
ceasefire by 72 hours so I'm hopeful
that will provide some respite but you
mentioned the borders where people are
crossing let's just leave Egypt
um for now I want to focus in on South
Sudan and Chad I mean South Sudan of
course people will remember as a country
that is already facing a humanitarian
crisis some to uh 0.3 million people
already internally displaced I mean how
equipped is a nation like South Sudan to
deal with it with an influx of people
looking at a scenario where South
Sudanese refugees in Sudan are being
forced to return to their country of
origin so uh
it's as bad as death as in you you fled
because of persecution because of
conflict uh environmental reasons and
then you're forced to go back that's
that's South Sudanese there will be also
Sudanese who will have to to flee uh
according to to where they are um so it
is it is extremely dire and they they
would need a lot of help to to be able
to accommodate these people but also to
keep the borders open because it is
really imperative that they keep the
borders open you mentioned that again is
there a danger that the borders could
get close into those two Nations
yes and it's it's not clear what the
process for people to cross is uh and
that's that's why there's a whole lack
of clarity
um which which we're hoping to find out
uh especially through the coordination
of the United Nations let's talk a
little bit about Darfur if we can uh
Carl
um obviously an area again uh in Sudan
that has faced um
much tribulation in recent years and
there are some 1.5 million refugees
already in that region um fighting is
flaring there what's your understanding
I understand the NRC do have a presence
down there
we do my colleagues Are all uh on ad
right now and figuring out their next
movements if there is any possibility of
that as the fighting intensifies we have
uh colleagues across star four uh also
in Janina and the fighting is really
intensifying getting Wilder as we go
during what is uh officially as his fire
um so yes my colleagues Sudanese and
experts um are rolling it together and
they they are literally fleeing for
their lives um as as we speak and Carl
just uh finally then talk to us about
what's needed from the International
Community to try and help these areas I
mean we've laid out in our conversation
just how uh those that already
internally displaced those that have
already fled uh war and suffering are
now being forced to to flee again what
kind of International effort is needed
to try and give these people the
resources that they need at this time
well first of all we need every pressure
possible uh whatever there is to even
intensify further to with the two
warring parties uh despair civilians to
stop to stop this Insanity that is that
is tearing apart the country and to give
us a real respite so that we can reach
the most vulnerable we have been unable
to work uh on the ground since all this
started on the 15th of April my
colleagues who were under Fire and and
we can't reach the most vulnerable
before all this started 16 million
Sudani people in Sudan needed
humanitarian assistance imagine how many
more now uh being on the Move carrying
nothing desperately for water and food
and and the shelter and of course you
need the the International Community to
be generous with its funding when we get
to really responding we're not there yet
we're not even responding because the
fighting is not allowing us to and we
hope that the real ceasefires are agreed
to and and that the two parties stop
making Hashem of their own announcements
uh because it has been deadly they've
broken their own ceasefires and
civilians have died and are also
colleagues of ours in the aid sector
that's right okay uh Carl uh schembry
from the Norwegian Refugee Council
appreciate your time this evening and I
wish you all the very best in your luck
and to your colleagues thank you very
much for being with us